it's about a year overdue but corrupt
crony capitalist clown scott pruett
Donald Trump's EPA director has finally
been forced to resign his position at
the EPA adding on to the very long and
growing list of Donald Trump top level
resignations or forced resignations or
some people call them firings to call
scott pruett beleaguered would be an
understatement the countless ethics
investigations into everything from
using lobbyists condos for 50 bucks a
night his absurd first-class travel
expenditures of taxpayer money having
epa staff do special favors for him
personally that have nothing to do with
his role as a cabinet member and just
being an all-around horrible person and
leading an agency that he regularly
tried to hamper via lawsuits before he
was its director and in his resignation
letter Pruett says that one of the
reasons he's resigning are the quote
unrelenting attacks on him personally
the reason he's being attacked is
because he's horribly corrupt and
terrible for the environment that he's
supposed to be protecting but that's
expected right these guys will always
say it's not that they did something
wrong it's that it's become a
distraction because of the unfair
targeting of them for the things they
allegedly did wrong of course
well it's impolite we got to be civil
here it's impolite to target them in
such a way we need to police our tone
actually when we talk about all of the
misdeeds of Scott Pruett and even though
it's being called a resignation Trump
told him it's time for him to resign in
more practical terms we call that
getting fired and reportedly what pushed
huddled Trump over the edge was that it
leaked to the media that Pruitt
previously asked Donald Trump to fire
Attorney General Jeff sessions so that
Pruitt could run the Justice Department
and apparently news of that was just too
embarrassing to Trump it's an absolute
and total comedy of errors and as I've
been saying all along
just because Pruitt should be out
doesn't mean it'll get better if you
replace him and case in point
with no delay whatsoever Monday acting
EPA director Andrew wheeler takes over a
former coal lobbyist okay uh youyou
couldn't predict this except that it was
completely predictable as soon as we
realize that drain the swamp was
actually filled with swamp yeah I mean
I'm sure the environment will worsen at
the same rate that it was before right
maybe isn't much better but maybe there
will be fewer scandals and we can take
that as a tiny bit of a win that can be
a win but it also can be a loss in the
same way that if pens took over for
Trump fewer scandals and constant foe
paws would probably mean that pence
would get more of his agenda done in the
same way Andrew wheeler coal lobbyist
Andrew wheeler might actually get more
environmental destruction done by being
less scandal-ridden that Scott Pruett
was Prewitt candidate cabinet member
number five to be forced out we had Rex
Tillerson Secretary of State Secretary
of Veterans Affairs Secretary of Health
and Human Services Secretary of Homeland
Security and now number five EPA
director and of course we can add to
that CIA director James Comey being
fired press secretary Sean Spicer going
National Security Adviser already on
number four after the indictment of
Michael Flynn some interim guy whose
name I don't even remember
followed by HR McMaster going and I'm
not even gonna get into White House
communications director where there have
been five plus dozens and dozens of
other roles now if you're worried about
Scott Pruitt's future and I don't think
that many people in our audience are
he's done enough as EPA director to help
the polluters make more money that he is
going to have no problem getting some
really sweet lobbying gig yeah I mean he
wanted to be Attorney General right
there's now a new opening at the Supreme
Court maybe he could throw his hat in
the ring why not right and the real
tragedy here is that because Pruitt
resigned he's mostly going to be
forgotten
he should be investigated because the
guy's behavior is director of the EPA is
potentially criminal it's not out of
bounds to think he might be deserving of
prison time but when you resign you do
your damage you do your hatchet job and
then you disappear into lucrative
lobbying or whatever
political resignation leads to no
prosecution that's the American Way when
in reality the consequences should now
begin now that he's back to being a
private citizen this episode is
sponsored in part by better help.com
slash Pakman which gives you access to a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologist or therapist through video
phone and text I know from the emails I
get that in our audience like in the
broader world there are people who are
struggling with different issues in
their lives and many of them choose not
to talk to somebody about it either for
financial reasons for reasons of stigma
associated with seeking out a therapist
and I think it's really important to do
everything you can to get past that
because it's really important to talk to
someone when you feel like that's the
right thing to do and what better help
calm provides is number one the
elimination of the stigma that could be
associated with it you work through
video phone whichever method is best for
you you also will be able to save money
compared to seeing an in-person
therapist and it is so easy to get
started that I encourage you to go to
better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa que ma n